signori miei sull'ultimo episodio di oca
simulator chiamiamolo così teoricamente
ragazzi dovrei andare di qua perché mi
ero aperto questa strada ed era riuscito
a scoprire una cosa che non sia l'ultima
zona almeno spaccato tutti in casa
permesso grazie
c'è un pacco fred cosa c'è di qua
l'altro mi sono dimenticato di sbirciare
la videocamera effettivamente mettiamola
non è un horror saw gioco lo sembra lo
so però non lo è allora sono proprio
curioso di vedere cosa ci riserva questo
giochi incredibile in competizione con
the training devo capire al ringraziato
e il mio habitat nell'acqua ragazzina
ferrarista stavo capua dove vado il cusi
cos'è che c'è di qua che un ora che giro
e l'altra parte del giardino nuove lo
ricordate raga ma non sono tornato nel
giardino sa come ma come eva scusami ma
è sempre stato aperto sul posto sono
tornato indietro
macao look se all'inizio del gioco
bellissimo e quindi chiusi c'è nessuno
qui io sono una lettera che devo
consegnare a qualcuno ancora capito chi
salve e scusi della posta qua è sua
le piace vabbè visto pezzetto portato
dura la posta allora i dammela pezzente
una prova fa le cose giuste ma da voi
chi con cio adesso io sono solo un oca
tranquilla e la gente mi tira ma guarda
che odiosi come la morte mamma mia sono
ti faccio del male guarda non lo so ma
se io provassi invece entrare
velocissimo porca vacca colom i parà
proprio un portiere maledizione agricolo
sta portando i pacchi e se invece
portarsi un pacco forse mi fa entrare
perché colori vede che porta i pacchi
alla prostata io l'ho portata non marca
gato forse devo trascinare quel pacco
dono gigante o questo addirittura a no
mi infilo dentro
potrei tirarmi dentro il parco non
servono idea stupida vediamo
non lo so e mi infilo dentro mi chiudo
oppure all trascina dentro e basta
guardare cento
un corriere sono un corriere non hanno
sofferto ecco solid snake
ma come sono io pezzente ma potevo
veramente fare questa cosa vedo la mia
dammi il pacco o sono entrato entra nel
pub sono entrato anche se mi ha lanciato
occhio non ci passa qui sotto sono
entrato in punti incredibili solid snake
ragazzi giorno ciao ragazzi tutto come
andiamo state trasmesse un'ora entrare
tutto bene sono io un'area tra faccio
parte della trazione desidera prendo le
ordinazioni se vuole no è la tipa l'ipia
cosa è l'unica persona che mi ha
guardato in modo dolce da quando
iniziato sul gioco salve vorrei qualcosa
mangiare mi ha guardato come diceva che
stai facendo
posso prenderla ecco la mia questa
[Musica]
eccoci no mi serve spettatori ti credevi
la fisarmonica ajax non lasciava
lasciami avviso ormai poiché perfetto
avete mai visto un aiuto
un'altra che suona la fisarmonica e io
che volevo la fisarmonica processo a
prenderla se faccio il giro
porca vacca da passare sotto i tavoli a
sono sotto il tavolo tactical espionage
action a ma vivi che cielo le cose da
fare una polemica lettera rompere il
bersaglio delle freccette prendere la
barca dei giochi far cadere il signore
anziano ricevere in premio un fiore
rubare un boccale lanciarlo nel canale
vederlo prende allora ragazzi buttiamo
il suo coso nel canale che per uscire un
miracolo cioè devo fare un casino
però spero di riuscirci alla loro l'ho
rubato fa niente il problema è passare
dall entrata e porca vacca è
difficilissimo passaler non so come si
debba fare sta parte perché forse mentre
mi insegue quindi adesso posso farlo
perché mi sta inseguendo teoricamente
meno che non è non è spalmato pro parco
lemonia non c'è manco un boccale allora
se io appoggio questo qui ok lui mi
segue poi faccio il giro
ok perfetto perfetto l'effetto effetto
c'è perfetta una sega realtà dell'ondata
di sopra fammi andare lì sopra bravo
no no no
porco demonio togliti ok bravissimo non
ci credo ce l'ho fatta un'ora e mezza
oddio che è successo si è persa la
webcam perché perché 70 la webcam allora
mentre a voi disattivato la webcam del
tutto questo suscita prendere il boccale
a lanciarlo nel canale
bene allora ga abbiamo prima barca dei
giochi la barca dei giochi immagino sia
la barchetta giocattolo con un italiano
fatto veramente da schifo trova bene
riempiti veloce prima che arrivi la
tizia occhio che ci dobbiamo tipo
ronaldinho brava bravissima salivoli e
teoricamente afferrano barca dei giochi
a sopresa l'ho presa mia è mia
non so neanche cosa ci fai cosa te ne
fai gli staro che però la prendo grazie
gentilissima te ne frega niente proprio
mela sta tirando a me è bravo zio
complimento o lo posso che prendere anno
cosa frena la freccetta ma porca vacca e
ho fatto quasi tutto far cadere sedere
di sedere il signore anziano che allora
quando si siede ritiro cose se sì si può
fare perfetto mammamia poverino
[Musica]
mammamia ragazzo veramente la persona
l'oca più orribile del pianeta cioè
vergonoso ricevere i premi un fiore che
immagino sia quello perché sono gli
ultimi gli unici che mancano per
interagire come gli europei diana luna
c'è la freccetta d'acqua e cazzo sei un
cane
devo fare certo che siete entrambe
laureate ad harvard
sono proprio una calabria donne ei
grazie grazie gentile non dovevate
milady nuovo elemento per chiuso
l'affare quest'anno curiosissimo punto è
finora un gioco
ma cosa vuole ora mio ma l'ho vinto io
basta pezzente possono fare tirare un
secchio in testa all uomo robusto eccomi
adesso dovreste riuscire a venir vi qua
perché gli fa ci sono i pomodori
teoricamente se tu prendi il pomodorino
che lo lascio quindi ricavi che funzionò
ragazzi credibile una tattica che uso
funziona se tu prendi il pomodoro
teoricamente per riuscire a farti
arrivare così in testa subito ma la che
mira se ci riesco incredibile ciao ciao
ciao fatta subito ce l'ha fatta subito
e lui dopo augusto no qui me lo dovresti
dare dati sono anche la fisarmonica come
eva gioco dell'anno comunque non vorrei
dire salve entrare nel villaggio in
miniatura rubare la campana d'ora in
miniatura l'unico obiettivo è questo
e sono tutti livelli che ho fatto in
miniatura fighissimo vice il giardino
c'è la parte coi tizi bellissimo la
campana d'oro e dov'è che ne so no vabbè
ma il gioco fatto in miniatura
bellissima voce la parte nuova che stavo
facendo adesso però non ho capito
dovrebbe essere la campagna parte dico
non ci passo meno che non hanno
abbassando la testa ci passo bellissimo
ok
e questa è la miniatura della miniatura
è giusto e poi c'è un castello eccola
l'ho trovata devono rompere il castello
mio dio tira via tirano tirano dai che
c'è il gran finale
credo sia gran finale perché dovrebbe
finire dopo il terzo livello questo è
già un quarto livello permette ai chiama
donna sai moltissimo e mi sono
incastrato ok no guarda la palla d'oro
in miniatura cielo e quindi nuovo
elemento e riporta la fino a casa io
dovrei portare all'inizio al primo
livello giusto
qui devo rifarmi tutto con la campana
che sarà difficile perché immagino che
la campana in qualche modo avverta la
gente che quindi i denti non tutti
quanti di prendermi ragazzi ci provo la
riporto a casa va bene devo trip l'army
tutta la gente in modo tale che innova
day difficilissimo e che poi
diventeranno di rubarle amara ma perché
ovviamente perché d'oro aiuto aiuto
no no la mia caparra e la mia caparra no
via vai bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
velocissimo ci sono strina spinoff in
aiuto nel canale del canale come si
scende posso salutarmi giunto giù di
brutto giu non mi possa buttare giu non
mi posso buttare giù cave fa niente
[Musica]
maledizione che è difficile a vari
quadri qua tornava all'inizio no
all'inizio non ciò che nessuno
teoricamente non c'è più nessuno
teoricamente questo era proprio
all'inizio inizio quindi immagino che a
casa sia questa dentro il mio cespuglio
ma come lei ho trovato un sacco di
campane rilievo è un loop se è vero
ragazzi questo è il più bel finale del
mondo credo che sia ancora migliore di
colori getting over it
ragazzi io non so che dire questo era il
gioco dell'oca oca simulator
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come
al solito se vi è piaciuto assorbimento
che mi piace iscritti al canale perché
tanti video come questi non mi vedrete
nessuna parte perché
importanti come questo ci sono solo in
pochi canali su youtube
questo è uno di quelli ragazzi quindi
spero che vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
schiacciate la campale riina era come
sempre ci vediamo al vostro video bella
ragazza
[Musica]